[Music]
the congregation built from early in the
morning
50 000 people coming to the Vatican to
bid a farewell to Benedict the first
pope to resign from his job in six
centuries
it was a full papal funeral in Albert
name and what was so notable Benedict's
service was overseen by his own
successor Pope Francis himself now
hindered by ill health but determined to
lead the way
foreign
Church in Britain blessing mourners here
and acclaiming Benedict anybody who met
him came away with that sense of a man
who was warm who was courteous with who
to whom you could relate no matter the
difficulties that were being tackled and
I think that's what spread as it were
among people today they were saying
goodbye to somebody who's just lovely
Benedict resigned nine years ago but
continued to live here in the Vatican
on a cold and Misty morning this
remarkable spectacle of one Pope
conducting the funeral service for his
predecessor and it raises important
questions about the way Pope Francis
will now lead the church and whether he
is thinking about his own future and his
own retirement
Pope Francis did look frail today he's
now 86 older than Benedict Was when he
retired it marks the end of this era of
the two popes or this era of having a
pope Emeritus a retired Pope at the same
time as an active Pope
um now going forward we'll see what Pope
Francis does but for many today's
service the church's future is a
question for another day for them this
was all about remembering Benedict
he could see him practically defending
the Fate
by Thoughts by actions and by writing of
which through his writings it's like a
legacy left for the church
I am really thankful for him especially
for his being
so faithful in the church and his humble
service to the Chiefs special Grace and
his special courage he is a brave man I
like him
this was the moment when one Pope kissed
goodbye to another and the world Bid
Farewell to Benedict he was buried in a
crypt underneath Saint Peter's Basilica
a tomb once used by Pope John Paul II
now the resting place of his friend and
successor
Adam Parsons Sky News Vatican City